I'm on location at a small mom-and-pop
business that just made a fool of Ron
DeSantis all they had in their Corner
was 200 billion dollars in market cap
and thousands of the world's best
lawyers but not only did they make a
fool of Ron DeSantis they did it in the
most legally hilarious way possible yeah
so is Florida Governor Ron DeSantis vs
Disney in a fight to the death and
they're going head to head in a romp in
the swamp and only one will emerge
Victorious and so far well it's Disney
one DeSantis zero and you'll have to
stick around until the end to learn of
the hilarious legal way that they
actually won this one now I know what
you're asking did legal eagle come to
Disneyland just to film one sight gag no
I came here for many sight gags the
trouble all started in March of 2022
when Florida's republican-dominated
legislature passed House Bill 1557 aka
the parental rights and Education Act
aka the don't say gay Bill the law bans
discussion of sexual orientation or
gender identity for students in
kindergarten through the third grade in
Florida public schools to protect quote
fundamental right of parents to make
decisions regarding the upbringing
control of their children in a specified
Manner and it also requires schools to
out students to their parents as gay or
trans meaning that the child of any age
who is struggling with their gender
identity comes to a guidance counselor
or trusted teacher the school cannot
maintain confidentiality about this
discussion and must disclose it to the
parent as part of the child's
educational record somebody who does
want to step out of the closet we open
the door for them and the bill creates a
private right of action for parents to
sue schools for violating this statute
and recover monetary damages including
legal fees now the law had quite a few
vague terms and when this was being
debated in the legislature state senator
Lori Berman wondered if the obligation
to disclose any change in the student
services or monitoring related to these
students mental emotional or physical
health or well-being would require
schools to inform parents of a student
requested a vegetarian meal for lunch
and the bill sponsor state senator
Dennis Baxley agreed that it would but
if the Bill's intent was to banish any
mention of lgbtq people from Florida
schools his educated struggles to comply
with a vaguely worded law under threat
of cripplingly expensive litigation it's
been a rousing success teachers in Pasco
and Duval County schools were ordered to
remove safe space stickers from their
classrooms for fear of running afoul of
the don't say gay Bill even Rainbows are
being removed less teachers be accused
of indoctrinating kids the Sarasota
County School District published a flow
chart for staff when a student requests
to change their name or pronouns and
unless until parents give permission the
answer will be no and Governor DeSantis
is then spokesperson Christina Pusha
tweeted if you're against the
anti-grooming bill you are probably a
groomer or at least you don't denounce
The Grooming of four to eight-year-old
children silence is complicity this is
how it works Democrats and I didn't make
the rules DeSantis himself echoed this
language when he signed the bill into
law on March 28 2022 at a private
Charter School in Tampa they support
sexualizing kids in kindergarten and
that of course put him on a direct
Collision Course with Florida's largest
employer Disney because Florida's don't
say Gabriel sparked a furious backlash
and the Walt Disney corporation which
has long positioned itself as an lgbtq
friendly business brings in major
tourism dollars for Florida's economy
one 2019 study found that the company
was responsible for 75.2 billion dollars
in annual economic impact for Central
Florida supporting 463 000 jobs and 4.8
billion dollars in state tax revenue it
also contributes millions of dollars in
campaign contributions every election
cycle and yes before you write it down
in the comments I am fully aware that
all this is taking place in Florida at
Disney World not in California at
Disneyland but I didn't want to go to
Florida have you seen who they have
elected there and as it became clear
that the legislature was actually going
to pass the Bill Disney's then CEO Bob
chappick faced intense criticism for not
using the company's clout to fight it
his own employees staged walkouts in
March of 2022 and set up a website
called where is traffic to demand action
for his part chappick told shareholders
he'd been working behind the scenes to
fight the bill and he apologized to
Disney's lgbtq employees saying quote I
missed the mark in this case but I am an
ally you can count on and I will be an
outspoken Champion for the protections
visibility and opportunity you deserve
chappix allyship didn't last long though
he was ousted in November when his
predecessor Bob Iger came out of
retirement and took the job back on
March 28th when the bill was signed into
law the company finally put out a
statement of tepid criticism suggesting
that the law quote should never have
passed and should never have been signed
into law quote our goal as a company is
for this law to be repealed by the
legislature or struck down in the courts
and we remain committed to supporting
the national and state organizations
working to achieve that we're dedicated
to standing up for the rights and safety
of lgbtq Plus members of the Disney
family as well as the lgbtq plus
community in Florida and across the
country at which point Disney found
herself in the middle of a category 5
social media storm dealing with the
backlash to the backlash from the
right-wing supporters of the bill itself
and as a result Governor DeSantis and
his allies vowed revenge on Disney for
daring to criticize the law at a press
conference on March 29th science is
branded Disney a bunch of quote
California corporate Executives he said
quote I think they crossed the line
we're going to make sure we're fighting
back when people are threatening our
pair parents and threatening our kids
and here we are at It's a Small World
which is actually the birthplace of Ron
DeSantis now in a fundraising email he
threatened reprisal tying it explicitly
to the company's criticism quote if
Disney wants to pick a fight they chose
the wrong guy I will not allow a woke
corporation based in California to run
our state Disney has gotten away with
special deals from the state of Florida
for way too long lieutenant governor
Jeanette Nunez was even less subtle
likening Disney to the Chinese Communist
party and insisting the company had no
right to criticize the government which
is of course not how this works or maybe
that's exactly how it works in Florida
where the government just made it
illegal for teachers to acknowledge
their own families and ban drag shows
yeah so you know California doesn't have
those laws California also doesn't have
horrible humidity so maybe if you're
thinking about going to Florida maybe go
California and Disneyland instead but
the Florida legislature raced back to
Tallahassee to figure out some way to
stick it to the state's main economic
engine and what they settled on was
repealing a special tax zone for the
benefit of Disney called the Reedy Creek
Improvement District now naturally they
also tried to draw a line between the
government action and the company's
protected First Amendment speech for
instance state senator Spencer roach
tweeted on March 30th quote yesterday
was the second meeting in a week with
fellow legislators to discuss a repeal
of the 1967 Reedy Creek Improvement act
which allows Disney to act as its own
government if Disney wants to embrace
woke ideology it seems fitting that they
should be regulated by Orange County so
what is the Reedy Creek Improvement act
well that requires us to go back to 1965
when Florida Governor Hayden Burns
welcomed a new neighbor to the Sunshine
State Florida already has many world
famous tourist attractions and the new
Disney complex promises to complement
these existing businesses and will
greatly increase the magnetism of
Florida's Dynamic personality now the
Walt Disney Company promised to do for
Orlando what it had done for Anaheim
California with the Disneyland theme
park to incentivize the company to build
Walt Disney World Florida created a
special tax district for the 25 000
Acres of heretofore worthless swampland
the company had bought up an orange and
Osceola counties and according to
Florida's uniform special district
accountability act a special district
means a unit of local government created
for a special purpose as opposed to a
general purpose which has a jurisdiction
to operate within a limited geographical
boundary and is created by General law
special acts local ordinance or by rule
of the governor or cabinet so in plain
English a special district is a
government authorized Regional body
dedicated to a specific purpose like
Community Development or fire or rescue
or this being Florida mosquito control
and truth be told Special Districts
aren't really all that special the
state's website lists uh
1932 of them at last count ranging from
the Amax Brewer Memorial law library to
the zephyrhillas community redevelopment
agency but the Reedy Creek improvement
district was pretty special in that it
was so wide-ranging the original 1967
Charter gave the Improvement District
board which was controlled by the Walt
Disney Corporation dozens of powers the
rcid had the authority to build roads
and sewage systems to contract with
neighboring Police Department for
security to enact a mosquito control
plan and the law Exempted it from
virtually all zoning laws it even gave
the rcid the right to collect taxes at
triple the rate of any county or city
essentially the charter allowed Disney
to function as its own independent
municipality an arrangement which worked
out well for everyone for some 55 years
until the mouse got too big for Bridges
and started talking back to the governor
so in 2022 after Disney criticized the
don't say gay law Governor DeSantis and
his allies decided to kneecap Mickey by
revoking the charter of the Reedy Creek
improvement district his buddies in the
state senate raced back to Tallahassee
to enact sb4 a bill which purported to
dissolve the Reedy Creek improvement
district itself well to be more accurate
it dissolved quote any independent
special district established by a
special act prior to the date of
ratification of the Florida Constitution
on November 5th 1968 and which was not
re-established re-ratified or otherwise
reconstituted by special act or general
law after November 5th 1968 but you
probably saw this coming the only
District affected by this law would be
Reedy Creek and Orlando land use lawyer
Jacob Schumer immediately spotted a huge
problem with his plan to stick it to
Disney because a lot of Special
Districts were empowered to issue bonds
but the rcid charter had a special
provision where in the state of Florida
pledged not to impair the rights of
bondholders until quote all such bonds
together with interest thereon and all
costs and expenses in connection with
any action or proceeding by or on behalf
of such holders are fully met and
discharged and so dissolving the Reedy
Creek District would cause the bond debt
to land squarely in the lap of the local
government and while Disney can easily
pay the 58 million dollar annual Debt
Service on the billion dollars worth of
bonds Osceola and orange counties cannot
but DeSantis vowed to fight on saying
quote in the near future we will propose
additional legislation to authorize
additional Special Districts in a manner
that ensures transparency and an even
playing field under the law and his
spokesperson vowed that no Florida
taxpayer would see the rates go up as a
result of the governor's mission to
punish Disney for standing up for lgbtq
kids now in the event that the
legislature passed a substitute statute
for SP Before the bill also renamed the
Reedy Creek District the central Florida
tourism oversight district and created a
new board filled with DeSantis
appointees the panel includes several
DeSantis donors with strong ties to the
Republican party for instance DeSantis
also named Bridget Ziegler a co-founder
of moms for Liberty a group of
self-described Joyful Warriors and the
culture who fight mask mandates and
transgender students going to the
bathroom her husband is co-chair of the
Florida GOP who donated 1.75 million
dollars to DeSantis she's joined on the
board by Pastor Ron Perry who once
described homosexuality as evil and
shared a conspiracy theory the tap water
might be making people gay basically
sending a message out of Disney ever got
any bright ideas about speaking up
against the governor again the board
would ensure that the company would
deeply regret it or as DeSantis put it
quote when you lose your way you gotta
have people that are going to tell you
the truth all these board members very
much would like to see the type of
entertainment that all families can
appreciate Jacob Schumer the lawyer who
spotted the bond problem with the first
bill told the Washington Post quote the
district is basically exactly the same
but now Disney World will go from being
abnormally independent to being
abnormally controlled they still get
their special little district with taxes
that can pay for lavish roads and luxury
projects but they're no longer pulling
the strings in February de Santa signed
the new bill into law congratulating
himself for a Flawless victory over the
world Corporation but it turned out the
mouse still had a couple of tricks up
its sleeve so because descendants people
hadn't been paying a lot of attention to
the board they failed to notice the
legally mandated notice posted in the
Orlando Sentinel on January 27th
advertising a board meeting on February
8 2023 in the boardroom of the rcid
administration building at that meeting
the outgoing board members voted to
adopt a new Declaration of restrictive
covenants and buried in a lot of
legalese the documents needed most the
board's powers to Walt Disney parks and
Resorts which meant that the new board
wouldn't be able to withhold approval
for most of the things that Disney
wanted to do now it took the incoming
board members almost two months to work
out exactly what had happened in fact it
wasn't until their second meeting that
they realized that they had been out Fox
by Disney yeah so I don't know maybe the
original problem here is that the State
of Florida seated basically unfettered
government-like power to a huge
corporation and now they're reaping the
repercussions of that I don't know
maybe maybe that's not a good idea who
knows I'm just a lawyer Ron Perry the
anti-gay water Pastor complained quote I
cannot tell you the level of my
disappointment in Disney I thought so
much better of them this essentially
makes Disney the government this board
loses for practical purposes the
majority of its ability to do anything
beyond maintain the roads and maintain
basic infrastructure new board member
Bridget Siegler tweeted quote the
arrogance of at Disney continues from
ignoring parents and allowing radicals
to sexualize our children to now
ignoring Florida taxpayers by sneaking
in a last-minute sweetheart development
agreement Disney has once again
overplayed their hand in Florida we
won't stand for this and we won't back
down if unlawful actions were taken this
development agreement will be nullified
for his part DeSantis vowed Revenge rest
assured you ain't seen nothing yet
there's more to come in that regard and
the governor immediately dispatched an
army of taxpayer-funded attorneys to
attempt to unwind the deal a statement
attributed to four separate law firms
reads quote the lack of consideration
the delegation of legislative authority
to a private Corporation restriction of
the board's ability to make legislative
decisions and give giving away public
rights without compensation for a
private purpose among other issues
warrant the new board's actions and
direction to evaluate these overreaching
documents and determine how best the new
board can protect the Public's interest
in compliance with Florida law then the
state's top lawyer Florida attorney
general Ashley Moody sent a public
records request to the Reedy Creek board
members demanding all Communications
quote discussing an intention or goal of
circumventing avoiding frustrating
mitigating or otherwise attempting to
avoid the effects of anticipated actions
by the Florida governor and the Florida
legislature in the meantime DeSantis
sent a letter to the state's Chief
Inspector General Melinda Miguel
demanding that she investigate the board
for quote collusive and self-dealing
Arrangements aiming to nullify the
recently passed legislation undercut
Florida's legislative process and defy
the will of Floridians apparently he
believes that it would be unethical or
even criminal for the rcid board members
to consult with Disney Executives on the
rcid contract despite the company being
a party to the rcid contract but the
Counterpoint here is well taken there
are those that argue that Disney is
trying to frustrate the Democratic
process people elected their leaders in
Florida the leaders in Florida have
enacted several laws that seek to revoke
the special district that Disney was
benefiting and by trying to frustrate
that special district and those laws
Disney is being anti-democratic and it's
hard to argue against that it's just
that it happens to be on a backdrop of
potentially protected First Amendment
rights and this whole culture War new
Disney CEO Bob Iger called out to
Santa's at a recent Disney shareholder
meeting saying quote the governor got
very angry about the position Disney
took and it seems like he's decided to
retaliate against us including the
naming of a new board to oversee the
property and the business in effect it
seems to punish a company for its
exercise of constitutional right and
that just seems really wrong to me Eiger
went on to accuse the governor of being
anti-business fighting words in today's
GOP and now we get to the extremely
wonky but Extreme juicy legal details of
how Disney actually pulled this off
because Disney's lawyers say that
everything they did was strictly in
accordance with the law and if they're
right it will be thanks in part to an
ancient legal principle which has
bedeviled Law students for Generations
how many generations well a lot in fact
we have to go all the way back to the
17th century in England to the very real
and very much less spoken Kingdom of
Charles the first who reigned until 1649
when he literally lost his head
literally but in 1647 Henry Frederick
Howard the Earl of Arundel and Surrey
was faced with a problem by law the
eldest of his four sons was supposed to
inherit his estate unfortunately that
son Thomas was legally insane and
incapable of managing the Earl's vast
land Holdings furthermore it was
unlikely although not impossible that
Thomas would produce a son of his own to
inherit the estate and so the Earl and
his esteemed lawyer sir Orlando
Bridgeman devised a complicated plan to
divide the land and accompanying titles
among the four Sons upon the Earl's
death the will took into account
multiple contingencies with Clauses
shifting assets around at some
undetermined future date if Thomas
should die without an heir and
furthermore the Earl liked this crazy
Contraption so much that his will
imposed this plan to rotate assets among
multiple future Generations but by 1682
the Earl had died although not at the
guillotine and his second and third Sons
Henry and Charles were locked in an epic
legal dispute which came to be known as
the Duke of gloucester's case Henry
argued that the complex scheme of
Shifting ownership dictated by his
father's will was illegal because it
tied up property for too long and the
court agreed thus creating what became
known as the rule against perpetuities a
legal concept so famously complicated
that it has been included on every bar
exam for decades as a kind of hazing
ritual for the legal profession in
essence the Court held that it was bad
public policy to allow landowners to
lock up property forever I.E in
perpetuity and at the time England was
rapidly transitioning from a feudal
society to one based on capitalism and
trade and so it made sense that the
court decided that allowing landowners
to wall off great swaths of the
country's assets from sale would be a
hindrance to the new Mercantile economy
and this has become a foundational
principle of English and American common
law we don't like rules that say things
can't be sold and we really don't like
imposing restrictions on land sale or
use by Future owners so over the years
this rule against perpetuities has been
reduced to a simple Axiom no interest is
good unless it must best if at all no
later than 21 years after some life in
being at the creation of the interest
okay so maybe that's not particularly
that simple but in plain interest the
law will not allow you to dictate the
ownership of property forever the best
you can do is pick someone who is alive
at the time that the document is signed
and Peg your instructions to that
person's lifespan plus a maximum of 21
years after they die that person is
known as a quote life and being commonly
referred to as a measuring life and that
person doesn't have to be a party to the
contract you can make a measuring life
Miley Cyrus or Barack Obama or your
brother's new baby it doesn't matter it
just has to be someone alive at the time
of the contract all right so how does
this work in practice well let's say
this Scrooge McDuck wants to leave his
Mansion to Huey Dewey and Louis in his
will he writes I leave my home to my
beloved nephews for life and then to
their children when the last of them
reaches the age of 25. now in theory
Huey Dewey and Louie could father
children or ducklings on the last day of
their lives so this will violates the
rule against perpetuities because it
exceeds the measuring lives that's Huey
Dewey and Louis by more than 21 years
but change 20 5 to 21 and say my
nephew's lives plus 21 years and it's
probably all good so what does this have
to do with Ron DeSantis trying to burn
down Mickey's Clubhouse well Florida
like most States has modified his rule
against perpetuities it's no longer 21
years in fact in 2022 the state changed
the rule from 360 years to A Thousand
Years which is pretty optimistic
considering how much of the state's
population lives in coastal areas which
could be affected by sea level rise but
Disney and the rcid board knew that
DeSantis and his allies in Tallahassee
would be on the hunt for any possible
way to void the Declaration that strips
his appointees of power over the company
remember the rcid board and Disney just
watched the legislature pass multiple
laws aimed directly at them and and they
know that he's not above an acting a
17-minute rule against perpetuities that
only applies to Special Districts
established in 1967. so to protect the
company from that eventuality they
inserted this Clause quote it's a
Perpetual term of this declaration is
deemed to violate the rule against
perpetuities or any similar law or rule
this declaration shall continue in
effect until 21 years after the death of
the last survivor of the descendants of
King Charles III King of England living
as of the date of this declaration and
you should know in May King Charles will
be officially inaugurated as king of
England he has two sons five
grandchildren who are living as of the
date of this declaration so for the
purposes of this contract they are the
measuring lives Prince William's
children are Prince George age nine
princess Charlotte age 7 and Prince
Louis who is four Prince Harry's
children with his wife Meghan Markle The
Duchess of Sussex are Prince Archie who
is three his baby sister Princess
lilibet Diana mountbatten Windsor born
June 4th 2021 in Santa Barbara
California as the youngest of King
Charles's descendants living at the time
of this contract she is statistically
the likeliest to be the ultimate
measuring life of this contract behind
me is the Matterhorn and the fun bit of
trivia is that in order to extend the
contractual period even further Disney
has actually purchased the rights to
King Charles III he will be
cryogenically frozen so that he will
actually never die and be interned in
the Matterhorn so that all of the
contractual obligations will go on
basically forever so kids that's how
Mickey Mouse enlisted a real life
American princess to protect the fake
Magic Kingdom in a real-life battle to
protect the First Amendment yes because
Floridians love it when you antagonize
the state's largest employer I have to
admit coming to Disneyland alone as an
adult is a very strange experience
um the things I do for this channel
meanwhile the new board vows Too Fake
until they make it passing a resolution
restoring their power but for now they
are pretty much out of a job and if
DeSantis keeps going the 460 000 people
that Disney employs in Florida will be
out of a job as well so they could
really benefit from today's sponsor 80
000 hours they're a non-profit that
helps people find impactful and
fulfilling careers that aim at solving
the world's most pressing problems
because many sources simply give cookie
cutter advice and only recommend a few
well-known career paths that people
often think have high social impact like
being a doctor a teacher or a charity
worker boo no those are great but those
aren't your only options and they
probably aren't your best options either
trust me not one career aptitude test
told me to be a YouTube lawyer but most
importantly relevant career advice can
be really hard to find if you care a lot
about making a big positive difference
in the world and 80 000 hours is a
non-profit aims to help you find a
career that's both fulfilling and makes
big positive difference in the world the
name comes from the number of hours in
an average career 40 hours a week 50
weeks a year for 40 years that's a lot
of time and it means that your career is
probably your biggest opportunity to
have an impact in the world 80 000 hours
has done over 10 years of research
alongside academics at Oxford University
into how to find a fulfilling career
that does a lot of good and it turns out
that the best way to make a positive
difference might be pretty different
from what you think all the
recommendations are based on careful
research and consultation with experts
in relevant fields and when they aren't
sure of something they say so plus
everything they provide is free forever
because they're a non-profit their only
aim is to help solve Global Problems by
helping people find the most impactful
careers that they can so this one is a
no-brainer if you're thinking about your
career if you'd like a free copy of 80
000 hours in-depth career guide that
helps you learn what makes for a high
impact career get new ideas for
impactful paths and make a new plan
based on what you've learned just click
on the link in the description or the
one that's on screen right now you'll
also get access to their free newsletter
with updates on their research and high
impact job opportunities again all you
have to do is click on the link that's
on screen right now or in the
description to start planning a career
that is Meaningful fulfilling and helps
solve some of the world's most pressing
problems after that click on this link
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court yeah it really feels
like Disney should have sponsored this
one if anyone knows Bob iger's cell
phone number just drop it in the
comments